The creatures drew closer...
...but not too close.
Some of the creatures felt sorry for the crocodile.
"What's the matter with him?" asked a deer.
"I don't know," said a squirrel.
"Maybe he's going to die," chirped a bird.
"If that happens, it'll be safe to go in the river!" grunted a wild pig.
The animals thought about this.
They hung from branches, they hung from vines, they buzzed in the air,...
...and they shook their heads as they watched the great big crocodile in pain.
No animal tried to help.
Suddenly a little mouse appeared, sniffing the air.
He ran along the crocodile's tail, then onto his tummy.
The other creatures stared.
"Look at that mouse!" chattered a monkey.
"He's either very brave or mad!"
"He's going to be eaten for sure!" said an iguana.
The mouse crept along the crocodile's big neck and into his open mouth.
There was a hush in the forest.
The mouse got hold of something, and pulled and pulled and pulled.
Then he put it on his shoulder and walked out of the crocodile's mouth.
There was a loud cheer from the astonished creatures.